Oh
okay mister then hi okaythen hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to with the addition of
markiplier a fan made game that is gonna
be bumping and banging and moving and
grooving whatever Hooven means I guess
vacuuming I don't know what was that a
noise that I made my voice still isn't
100% but it's getting a little bit
better so I decided that I'm gonna play
a fan game that's gonna have a bit of
reading and hopefully I can be a little
bit more chill when I play it oh boy I
can't wait to record that new game asses
and angels I would love to play a game
named asses and angels my fans will love
it I bet you would just being honest
with you guys
mmm oh I look so cool my little sprite
wait a minute my computer's gone
there's only one explanation for this
I'm in a crudely paid fan game either
very funny
forever I'm stuck here until I finish it
oh stop that okay I didn't have time to
react you just stopped it I should find
some clues about what's going on here
hmm
it's my diary I definitely don't have
diary I pour all of my thoughts to you
guys and put them in a book
dear markiplier that's how I write it to
myself cuz I'm a narcissist oh isn't
that cute I addressed it to my Oh
this guy knows me a little too well I
guess today I sucked that's in reference
to an animation that MLG Haunt made of
me you can check it out in the
description below it's a really funny
animation oh that's enough laughter hey
I don't want to read that part of my
diary to everybody out there uh hum hum
fur um anyway a letter let's see what it
says dear mark I have stolen your
computer you will no longer be able to
make videos
I couldn't possibly just get another one
if you want it back you must find me and
stop me from destroying it huh good
thing I have several that this guy knows
me so well
PS I took your hard drives you know oh
you sneaky devil you yeah I should it's
weird I'm seeing the pictures of myself
and then I'm making the faces into the
webcam and I'm the exact same face cuz
it's me it's a little weird I should get
out of here and find this son of a [ __ ]
Humpty Dumpty sat on a wall Humpty
Dumpty had a great fall just like you
will if you don't keep looking come on
move it oh I see it's a bookshelf gonna
go on me it's all I advanced reading
material what of course I have advanced
reading material like this 100 that
Garfield and anyone read Garfield list
Garfield earth Garfield without Garfield
whatever it is it's just Jon Arbuckle
Shh we don't want anyone knowing about
though
newsmagazines even though you just told
everyone me me you need to be a little
bit more secretive because you're kind
of being a bit of a dick every man needs
flowers it for his room okay that's
quite a bold statement to make my throne
is a royal one that's a stool man Lisa
heads it's pink not that pink isn't
manly but come on now damn if only Bob
and way to here we would get shit-faced
and solve this problem ASAP absolutely
we would bro
it's a tubular nothing no work in here
not that I'm making notes mind you boxes
where's a crowbar when you need it I
still haven't finished moving in what
you wanted me to stay stay something
funny there's no time for that now
we have to look for a clue here but hey
this game is awesome I love it I think
that's enough time with that box let's
look at something else oh are you
talking to me now mr. mee oh whatever
I'll do what I want I love me some fresh
fruit say Healthy Kids that's a good
message this guy this guy's a stand up
developer I'm so manly
quite manly really manly really badly I
can't scream right now my voice still is
in a hundred percent whoa what the hell
well this place got decrepit fast I
thought this was my home but ah well
crap ain't going back that way I thought
it was gonna roll towards me whoo seems
to be some sort of ancient material for
all intensive purposes that's for all
intents and purposes the way is blocked
you think that I would know that Oh
teeny tiny mouse hole zero teeny tiny
mountain Oh [ __ ] Mouse
no they just bit my dong it's an old
book and thus the man wandered the old
building running from a creature far
worse than death but just his creeper
who was about to rip his face off it
stopped and cried in eerie howl the man
confused and petrified didn't know what
to do so he restarted his save file
the worst of fates hmm nothing of use in
here hello baby what are you doing with
your clothes on baby come on take oh
come on that's just perverted I wouldn't
say that
hey baby yeah baby yeah I just walked
the streets shouting in women to take
their clothes off or no shouting at
statues to dig whoo the graphics on this
table mmm
I can smell it all these are a lot of
quotes from my past there's to be some
sort of radical soda oh wait so I saved
my thoughts into wine yeah well I step
in these things are sort of shiny
there's so much detail Mark's grave
oh no okay I know this crudely made
grain but they could have at least wrote
here lies mark or something O'Shea holy
balls I have wings okay
ons whitey that's all I can make out lay
back and guessing lone crossed very hot
tit that seems like something I'd say I
think that's it I'm such a genius oh
yeah you keep thinking that mark so tiny
bugs him it's not like he's in every
other fangamer hey you shush I love it
when tiny box Tim is anywhere in fact I
got tiny box Tim right here he's my
little biscuit always gonna be here with
me cuz I'm back in my old place God well
not in my old place but I'm back in the
normal setup hello mark I've been
waiting for you call is gonna shred my
voice my little biscuit what have you
been up to nothing much just sitting
here nice booze come on Tim you can help
me find my computer before it's too late
okay oh he's so cute
maybe I can use my long wings to grab
her whatever's in there okay hey it's a
potion I'm gonna drink it dawn oh my
wing
please know maybe I needed that in the
future I don't know
let's do tiny box in oh I'm sure we will
wait was that supposed to mean it was
this muslimeen yamimash mark
oh no yamimash is heard now Yami don't
turn this into another fanfiction oh oh
you
ouch Yami I'm coming to help soap what
the cracks that don't step on them okay
we'll find a way wait is that a cup of
tea next to you huh
oh yeah CDs I'm quite thirsty all ever
drink no yamimash good fun you get your
strength up we'll find a way around
white way who's with you
only the most adorable tiny bugs him no
mark like what what what the hell
happened he did this to me - mark watch
him
Oh No for [ __ ] sake what is that what
is that that's not tiny much Jim at all
I don't think you know is your help
against work your computers made holy
balls you got ugly fast
Buddha lash I do not have enough power
yet to defeat you I will retreat for now
as for you you me Maj that he was
poisoned
farewell no I knew it yamimash no Tim y
ou know what I would be mortified if I
just had to watch Yami backside well
live and learn then get loves let's go
get Tim okay then I guess here's that
radical soda again I bet if I had my
wings I could have just flap my way
across and been fine but new I like that
Boulder that's a nice boat oh it's
beautiful
Oh Oh only a little bit of snippet of it
okay so all this is done Oh another text
entry the man wandered through the dark
and dank halls dreading what may be
around the corners he whispered to
himself I see a lot of pipes I don't see
a lot
yeah okay oh you dick oh you dick you
son of a [ __ ] okay I'm gonna go see doc
I can't go back I bet I fired my wings I
would be able to get across there but as
it stands right now I can't exactly do
anything to get around because of the
cracks in the floor hmm
oh hey baby I gotta go okay all right so
there was something shiny there but I
don't know if I'll be able to go back
well this has been nicer oh I can't go
back
Hey look a ham okay why I don't know why
why why did I get a ham why did I need a
ham yeah this one stinks worse than me
after I did that surgery whilst
exercising oh yeah where I fell down
it's gray my knees okay that's it hey
blue ball okay why do I okay why did I
do that reminds me of a certain Island I
still have that picture you know which
one which one what are you talking about
water island ostrich island what picture
I don't know what they're talking about
I should know so far there hasn't been
much inside these things
there was a blue ball that was awfully
nice I think I can squeeze through here
that's what she said he said where's he
getting these sound bites from they're
awesome I don't even remember saying him
half the time okay so I already know I
missed something now now baby sorry but
I don't know what I missed I bet if I
had my wings I would have been able to
flap over to Yami and save them I wonder
if I should go back and do that by now
but I've already saved over my file I
don't know if even mean anything if it
comes to it at the end of the game if
there's like multiple endings I think it
said there were I will go back and try
it again Tim you have to stop this right
now
I see that you're braver than I remember
I get braver every day I'm a man but I
also see that I don't remember his
original voice was that she walk crying
in my trap why
oh you're what's happening me now mall
the bar of log house Alicia's are
correct
ah shown you will be reduced to jelly
you'll be able to do nothing you will be
unable to move or speak that's driving
you completely insane
Oh what they want completely well I'm a
box not a rocket scientist
audios for now markiplier who do you do
you do okay
ha ha ha get back here you Busey okay I
guess that's it for me now hey baby
remember her baby baby hey baby hey it's
Tim's driving
Baga blinds always easy be behind it use
half I doctor said you painted I have to
fend for myself even when he says that
I'm his little [ __ ] I'll get even one
day I will
oh that's not one tiny box Tim says oh
that's not tiny box Tim I bet that's not
tiny box Tim Randy caciotta usual are
you did you look at this again okay see
what else here
Roy prison chamber left hidden room saya
hidden if you put the damn sign okay so
I guess I'll go to the hidden room I
think it wants me to go there I think
it's a trap boys nothing in here but
does it reminds me of something
something long ago from dust one of the
first or Let's Plays I did a long time
ago what do you expect me to find in
here I don't know but I'm gonna check
see more bricks
traitors stand is where you'll find an
item which is so refined okay oh look a
pretty dress shall I put it on oh yes -
I wish Yami were here oh I bet I could
have saved him nothing but cobwebs is
another one of Tim entries have straw
your work on the jelly inator if all
goes according to plan then mark will be
forced to live like I do of course it is
hard to make such a complicated device
with no arms or legs but what I do have
is would launch of it oh look a cute
little doll a fetus doll oh not like
from PT uh I'd be terrible more breaks
more breaks more breaks what is this ooh
an upside-down chair so spoopy okay so
all right then I guess huh on traitors
stand so if Tim was standing up here
then maybe uh oh
ah wait this is from that one game hello
mark
baby you're alive lass I am but a
figment of your imagination as soon as
we finish our conversation I will
disappear no baby that can't be true
I just wanted to thank you for all the
times you've greeted us as equals
whereas others would look upon us as
skanks would they
Oh baby don't give me such a big head
hahaha please accept these Cool Ranch
Doritos is a token of my gratitude not
sponsored by Cool Ranch Doritos obtain
Cool Ranch Doritos hmm thank you
farewell mark no baby not Oh Oh as this
as loud as my now can get one of my
voice is still little thrashed all this
game is so charming this game is so cool
I think there must be multiple endings
because I think there were choices that
I could have made so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna end the episode here
there's gonna be the first one that I've
actually done a multi-part series and
what I'm gonna do is at the start of the
next episode I'm gonna go back and see
if I can save yamimash because if I can
I definitely want to try that one first
but I also have this save file here such
that I could go back and try if there is
another ending that he's not there and
if I can't save them then I still got
this one so thank you guys so much for
watching thank you developer this game
there's so many references it's so
interesting it's so clever I love this
one this is phenomenal I love how much
work gets poured into these fan games so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I hope my voice is a little bit better
soon I hope you guys are still enjoying
cuz it's so much nicer to record in this
space than it is on the grump cache no
offense to them and a big thank you to
them for letting me use it while I was
troubles so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
I broke it I broke everything why did I
break everything
yeah Bob Oh God look at that oh my
goodness